(hip-hop music)
- I'm here with Keith
from The Try Guys
and he's gonna help me not
get trolled on the internet,
or how to react to it.
- Right.
- 'Cause I just
started doing videos,
and obviously people
are not very nice.
- Yeah.
- But people like you guys.
- Yeah well, you know a
lot of people refer to me
very affectionately as
a soy boy, super kind.
I found if you can just insult
yourself worse than they can,
they really have nothing left.
- What's the meanest thing
someone has ever said about you?
- The meanest thing
anyone's said about me,
I'm sure it was like, I don't
know, this dickless loser.
- Okay, I was called a fat
*****, how could I go lower?
- What about a **** ***  loser?
- So I just **** on myself more?
- Yeah, like, hi I'm
Keith the **** *** loser!
Then they would actually
be inclined to be like,
well no, you're
just a fat loser.
- I mean, I gotta be
honest, as a woman,
it's tough out there, somehow
there in those comments.
- You have it a lot
worse than I do.
The worse they're gonna do is
call me some leftist something
I mean, they'll be
much worse to you.
So, you need to figure out
how to track people's IPs
when they comment to you.
- Okay.
- And you know,
threaten them in person.
- I gotta be honest, your
solutions are terrible.
- Okay, well you
know, you asked.